إلى أوكرانيا الآن حيث تدعي الحكومة في
كييف أنها حققت نجاحًا جزئيًا
في هجومها المضاد ضد روسيا
وفقًا لنائب وزير الدفاع.
حققت القوات الأوكرانية تقدمًا على
جبهتين تشمل اتجاه
مدينة باكموت المحاصرة. CNN
تحدث سام [ __ ] حصريًا مع
فريق العمليات الخاصة الأوكرانية في باكلد في
جهودهم لترويض القوات الروسية،
شاهد هذا، إنها
عملية رائعة للقوات الخاصة الليلية
تهدف إلى جلب نوع خاص من
البؤس للقوات الروسية
عند وصولها إلى جانب
القوات النظامية الأوكرانية، هاجم الروس
تسجيلًا للرؤية الليلية لـ
هجوم روتيني احتاجته القوات الخاصة
للتغاضي عن المدة التي أمضيتها
تحت النار بهذه الطريقة قبل أن تتمكن من
التحرك
ثم ماذا فعلت
أم
[موسيقى]
حددت المراقبة الإلكترونية
ضحاياهم أولاً، قتلوا اثنين من
المظليين الذين اقتربوا من جناحهم
الأيسر للحصول على  إلى الأهداف الرئيسية للمجموعة، قال
القادة الروس بالقرب من باكموت، وهو سجل عقيم
لحدث بالغ القسوة في
مارس،
تم إطلاق النار على ضابط واحد
ثم آخر، كما
يقول، إن اعتراضات الراديو كشفت أن
الروس فقدوا ضابطين وخمسة
آخرين لفريق القناصة الخاص بهم في تلك الليلة التي تم
تشكيلها  عندما غزت روسيا أوكرانيا
العام الماضي، كان هذا الفريق من المحاربين القدامى ذوي الخبرة
يعمل في عالم سري تحت إشراف
أجهزة المخابرات، حيث تم
تكليفهم بالعمل التكتيكي الذي يسعى إلى
تحقيق تأثير استراتيجي حيث
يتشكل الهجوم المضاد لأوكرانيا
هنا باستخدام مدفع رشاش ثقيل معدل
في مخبأ مخفي الشهر الماضي  على مقربة من
مشغلي الطائرات بدون طيار من نوع باكموت، على بعد أكثر من ميل واحد،
يوجهون برابوس نحو القوات الروسية،
كم عدد الروس الذين قتلتهم في
هذه الحرب،
الكثير من
[الموسيقى]،
الكثير من الأجانب على سبيل المثال، كم عدد
أكثر أو أقل هناك، أوه، أنا لا أفعل ذلك.  لا أعلم أننا
لم نحسب فهمًا أن
الروس هم الذين يريدون إجراء
العد لأن أفضل أمل لأوكرانيا هو
أن تقوم القوات الروسية بالهرب بدلاً من
قتال
سام كايلي سي إن إن في شرق أوكرانيا
وينضم إلي سام كيلي الآن سام
وصول رائع مجرد
تقرير رائع بكل بساطة ماذا  المزيد، هل تعلمت المزيد
عن الهجوم الأوكراني المضاد
جيدًا، جون أعتقد أن
الشيء المهم بشأن
هجوم الحساب هو أولاً وقبل كل شيء أنه
قيد التنفيذ، وهو ليس على قدم
وساق بعد حيث يكون أكثر كثافة وأحدث
انفتاح أمامي هو بالفعل في
جنوبًا بين مدينتي زاباريسيا ودوني،
لذلك بالطبع
تمسك الأوكرانيون بالروس حيث
يقول الأوكرانيون ويزعمون
أنهم حققوا بعض
الاختراقات المحدودة على ذلك
الخط الروسي الذي تم الدفاع عنه بشدة هناك وهم
حريصون حقًا على الاختراق
بالكامل  لأنهم إذا تمكنوا من فعل ذلك،
فيمكنهم فصل الجبهة الجنوبية
عن الجبهة الشرقية، وسيمكنهم تقسيم
القوات الروسية أثناء توجهها جنوبًا
نحو احتلال شبه جزيرة القرم،
وهذا من شأنه أن يمثل
مكسبًا تكتيكيًا كبيرًا جدًا للأوكرانيين، لكن في
هذه المرحلة هم فقط  تحقيق
مكاسب إضافية هناك ولكن هناك
أيضًا حول باحمد حيث
كان برابوس وفريقه يقاتلون وينفذون
تلك الضربات بشكل فعال ضد كبار
روسيا والضباط والتي كانت أيضًا
بعض التقدم الأوكراني الذي من شأنه أن يسمح
لهم ربما بتطوير شيء
مفيد تكتيكيًا إلى
ميزة استراتيجية  جون